today we're going to talk about how to
use texture to create three-dimensional
depth like we see here let's get
[Music]
started hey everyone my name is Cameron
with motion science and if you're new to
the channel welcome today we're talking
about how to create 3D depth and after
effects using layers of texture it's a
really simple process it's something
that I've created before where I use a
motivational quote and the textures and
people have asked over and over again
how I created that so I want to show you
here in this example today how to do
that before we get started I do want to
remind you I have a free pdf guide over
at motion science. tvguide this is a
guide that teaches you how to use
organic techniques to create highlevel
cinematic motion design like you see
here on the channel so if you want to
learn how to create motion design like I
create which I call cinematic motion
design definitely go to motion science.
tvguide and download my free pdf guide
it's full of tips and tricks and you'll
absolutely love it now let's jump in
After Effects okay so here we are inside
of After Effects and right off the top
I've got a texture that I found online
uh it's like this dark kind of chalky
texture I would describe it uh it's
really cool looking I thought it'd be
really interesting to use it as a
background texture so that's what I have
here in the background I'm going to
click the 3D box and make it 3D then I'm
going to hit P for position and I'm
going to drop this back about 2,000
pixels so if I go to two views here
you're going to see
here's my layer kind of pushed back in
3D space next I'm going to do is I'm
going to add a camera so we're going to
go to layer new camera and we're going
to do one node camera preset 35 mm click
okay and now we have a camera sitting in
zspace I'm going hit P for position I'm
going to set a key frame for position
here and I'm going to move down into my
timeline and I'm just going to drop this
camera down something like this uh
actually let's go back to the begin
getting the timeline and let's bring the
camera up like this so what we're going
to do is just create a move where the
camera is dropping down like so now to
see this layer fully in the frame I can
do one of two things I can hit s for
scale on the background and I can scale
this up to something like this and you
know I could push the position up so
it's filling the frame here on the right
side let me go ahead and just drag this
over so we can see this better and you
can see but still it's it's not working
at the bottom so I either have to scale
it up even more or I can use an effect
that I like to use a lot of times which
is called
reptile so I'm going to double click on
reptile and it's going to bring up the
effects here and I'm just going to
expand down so you can see on the right
side the image is moving down and we're
going to change it from repeat to
unfold and now we've got an image that's
filling the frame so let's go ahead and
bring this key frame up a little
bit like this and we're just going to
change the position back to that point
good the beginning
and yeah that looks good there and on
this next key frame let's go ahead and
set a we're going to right click key
frame assistant easy ease in and that
just says okay when the camera comes in
it's going to come to a nice stop right
there great perfect so now at 4 seconds
let's set another key frames we're going
to click the stop watch there and we'll
move down the timeline and let's just
drag this down
somewhere in here something like that so
now we'll go back to our third key frame
we're going to rightclick and we're
going to say let's ease this one out so
it kind of comes out slowly and speeds
up and then we'll ease this key frame
in so if we look at our animation
here it kind of comes in stops and then
it moves again perfect I like that next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to go into um our position back to our
position we're going to hit alter option
and we're going to click to set an
expression and we're going to type in
wiggle parenthesis and we can try
different values here we'll do five and
we'll do a value of 100 so this says
that five times per second the camera
can move by an amount of 100
pixels and
you can
see it's pretty crazy
there it's quite a bit of motion let's
go ahead and switch this to half reses
cuz we are working with a larger image
here and let's just tweak that
expression and let's go down to maybe 05
and let's take this number down to maybe
70 and let's see what this does we'll go
back to one view yeah you can see now
it's just a much more subtle effect it's
looks like the camera just has a little
bit of float to it and then it kind of
moves on again that looks great so next
we're going to do is we're going to
bring in some type here and for this I'm
just going to command paste my type in
here and this is a a type face that I um
found that I liked it's northwell uh
regular and I just wanted to do an
inspirational quote which was the
fastest way to grow is to find a mentor
because it is 100% true and it's
something I really promoted motion
science so the fastest way to grow is to
find a mentor and what I did here is I
applied a fast box blur to this so if I
turn this off that is the type just
clean uh which sometimes is okay but a
lot of times one of my organic
techniques I like to use like I
referenced in my PDF guide is a fast box
blur or a gajin blur and I set it to a
very small amount and we'll
try1 so it's just very very subtle it
just kind of removes some of that
digital Edge digital crispness from the
type and it looks good so I pasted that
in and that is sitting at a position of
zero so if I was just to type this out
that's all I have to do that's literally
all I have to do if I just hit my type
tool and I
type the fastest way to grow I'm going
to select that type and I am going to
click the 3D box and I'm just going to
drag it over and drag it down
and that's exactly what I did with the
type that we
see here so now because it's in 3D
space um it just it sits there it's nice
the camera flies past it it looks really
nice I also just added a really simple
um text preset for just to fade in so
it's just fading in word by word by word
and I did that by going to apply
animation presets and under animation
presets I just selected word fade in
and it looks nice right so we're also
already getting some really nice depth
um next thing we're going to do is we're
going to select our type tool again and
we're going to type in the collective so
if you're not familiar what the
collective is it's a motion design
mentorship that I created uh inside of
motion science uh to help you with
mentorship so this this is like a little
you know ad for the collective that I'm
creating so there it is looks nice I can
align it like so but it does not react
to the camera right until I click that
3D checkbox but when I click it you're
going to see that it's going to kind of
disappear it's going to fly up on the
screen here because it's all of a sudden
it's reacting to the camera so there it
is up there so I'll just select Y and
I'm bringing it down just like that if I
didn't want to select the Y axi tool I
could also hit P for position and I
could just adjust the Y amount here
so that looks really nice and it flies
in the collective perfect I love it how
we can make this even more interesting
we can add additional textures over the
top so let's do that now so the first
texture I'm going to use here besides
the background texture which already set
up a nice texture for the environment is
we're going to use this texture Labs
film texture uh if you're not familiar
with texture Labs he creates some
awesome awesome textures that I
absolutely love and I find myself using
them quite a bit so I'm going to also
tick the 3D box here and we can't see
anything yet but let's go ahead and set
this to screen and now it's sitting over
the top you can see it's just it's
moving with the type right it looks
interesting but we can make it more
interesting by hitting P for position
and bringing it forward in zspace so if
I go back to my two views here you're
going to see here's our background
sitting back here here's our type
sitting in the middle ground and our
texture from texture Labs is also
sitting in the middle ground so let's
bring It Forward forward like so and
let's bring It Forward about 1,000
pixels so if you've seen any of my other
videos you know that I like to keep
things round numbers just for my own
sake and it's pretty large at this point
so we're going to hit s for scale and
we're going to scale this
down something like this now I could
keep it large and cover the entire frame
but I'm scaling it down because I want
to see more of the details so you can
really see the details here if you look
at the scratches uh it's really nice to
look at and it looks like it's working
just nice now here at the bottom we have
an issue where it's being cut off right
so again we're going to double click on
repeti we're going to change it from
repeat to unfold and we are going to
expand down and just drag this down like
so now it actually works out there's a
nice line here that's created underneath
the collective and I kind of just scrub
through this it is a little bit
distracting to me so I'm going to hit P
for position on that texture and I'm
just going to maybe drag this down maybe
it just kind of sits down here at the
bottom of the frame that's really nice
uh now it may create an issue at the top
of the frame where it's cut off let's
see if it
does yeah so we're going to also expand
up like
so and that's looking pretty
cool yeah so if you play this back now
we're going to take a look at how this
looks I'm just paying attention to these
scratch Textures in the foreground looks
really nice
nice you can see there's some really
interesting depth being created again I
may drag because I have a a wiggle
expression on the camera position you
know it moves around a little bit so
let's go ahead and just drag that down
just a little bit more so we just kind
of see the bottom Edge there make sure
the Top's still good yep we're still
good there going to go ahead and save
this and let's add another texture and
that's going to be texture number three
and this is again for my own textures
that I use a lot and it's another
scratch texture so we're going to hit 3D
on that as well and let's change that to
screen and let's also go ahead and
position this
one forward and zspace as
well now I don't want to go all the way
to a th000 pixels I want to go probably
in between so let's try 500 let's scale
it
down let's bring it here to the
top and let's go ahead and double click
on reptile as well and let's expand it
down just want to make sure I fill the
whole frame here so again you can see
here at the top I needed to really
expand that one
down save that and let's preview this
now you can see because one layer of
texture is 1,000 pixels forward another
layer is 500 pixels forward uh there it
creates multiple layers of dimension
inside of After Effects so as the camera
is kind of floating around it creates
this really
interesting depth in After Effects and
you know what let's go ahead and just
make the collective appear just like it
does for our other text we'll go into
our text animator and actually what I'll
do is I'll just go ahead and apply this
one straight up so you can see how this
works so we'll go to apply animation
preset animate in and we're going to do
Fade up words actually on this one we'll
do Fade up characters because it's just
a few characters hit U to reveal our key
frames
and maybe something like this let's see
how this looks and there we go that's
looking pretty
dope yeah I like that the collective is
revealed now something that's looking a
little bit weird to me is this repeating
texture up here on the left side and I
believe that was on on the texture Labs
so we can do is hit P for position and
we can you know move it over here to the
sides we don't really see
it make sure it's all good yep that's
looking good now going back to texture
three I want to apply the levels effect
here so let's go to color correction
levels and the reason I'm applying this
is I just want
to darken it up a bit something like
that so it darkens it up a bit and we'll
go to the film texture as well and we
will also apply levels to this one and
we're going to bring this
down somewhere in here so it's just
darker creates more contrast more visual
contrast so now we can really see those
scratches and
and you know dust and things like that
and maybe it's a little too too much
over the top I do kind of like it though
now you can see the subtlety here with
just texture three which I really like
this one a lot right so this is where
I'm going to go back and forth it's a
lot more
subtle especially on the edges over here
so let's go to a frame here like
that and we're going to turn levels back
on here and we're going to drop
down some of
this let's also try and rotate
it just to see here let's try
180 and I want to get rid of some of
those scratches it's a little too
much see how this is
[Music]
looking so I'll turn it off and on yeah
much more subtle it's not so over the
top um now we've got this weird artifact
back here at the top so let's hit P for
position and let's drag that to the very
top
there and we want to make sure our
entire frame is filled which it looks
like it is and I'm just watching it
frame by frame here just to see like
does everything look okay now we have a
weird artifact right
here so for this I think at this point
I'm going to scale it
up so it's out of the frame again I'm
looking at it frame by frame this is
super important that we go through
things frame by frame here so that we
can see any small details that look out
of place yeah that looks really nice and
then to finish this off I'm going to go
to layer new adjustment layer and I'm
just going to apply noise and grain add
grain go to final output yeah it's a
nice little effect and there we go and
that my friends is how I use texture to
create 3D depth in After Effects by just
layering texture layers one upon the
other sometimes I will do one texture
layer but a lot of times I add layer
upon layer upon layer in 3D space to
just give it that little added extra
depth it's all about the little details
right so you don't want to overpower
your piece with too much texture but you
don't want to use too little as well and
just a quick reminder go to motion
science. tvguide to download my free pdf
guide the complete guide to organic
motion design you'll absolutely love it
as always thank you for being here today
and I will see you in the next
[Music]
video